es ist ein ganz besonderes Duell
Vladimir Klitschko gegen Dieter Bohlen
kein bocksduell nein auch nicht der neue
DSDS Zoff sondern das ist wirklich ein
ernsthafter Streit über den Ukraine
Krieg und die Russland Sanktionen und
die beiden top-promis die streiten über
unseren Umgang mit Putin ganz genauso
wie sie zu Hause Millionen Deutsche das
derzeit in ihrem Alltag tun und Auslöser
ist dieser Auftritt hier von Dieter
Bohlen bei einem Unternehmer Event vor
dann plötzlich über die deutschen
Russland Sanktionen Herz zieht
aber ich bin eben der Meinung
wir sind ihr könnt mich ruhig ausruhen
ja aber wenn die diese Sanktionen zum
Beispiel nicht gemacht hätten und man
hätte sich vernünftig an einen Tisch
gesetzt ja dann bräuchten die Leute sich
jetzt nicht den ganzen fällefanz machen
ja die Leute jetzt müssen wir frieren
jetzt müssen wir dies und das das ist
doch alles scheiße von aus meiner Sicht
ja man kann das jetzt sehen okay mit dem
kriechen Ukraine man kann das immer
alles aber ich meine alles was da so
passiert und das Russland jetzt für viel
viel mehr Geld Gast nach Asien verkauft
und das ist ja ich meine das verstehe
ich alles nicht mehr jetzt
tja Dieter Bohlen versteht das alles
nicht und Vladimir Klitschko der
versteht Dieter Bohlen nicht und jetzt
ist der bei unserem Kollegen Paul
ronsheimer Wladimir Klitschko
ja ich stehe mit Wladimir Klitschko
mitten in Kiew Vladimir die das Zitat
von Dieter Bohlen in dem Video er sagt
Zitat
man hätte sich vernünftig an seinen
Tisch gesetzt dann bräuchten die Leute
jetzt nicht diesen ganzen Firlefanz
machen jetzt müssen wir frieren jetzt
müssen wir dies und das das ist doch
alles scheiße sagt Dieter Bohlen ähm du
hast darauf reagiert was geht ihr durch
den Kopf wenn du solche Worte hörst ich
glaube Dieter Bohlen hat verpasst was
passiert ist schon seit Ende Februar
seit der Anfang des Krieges und ich
glaube dass er einfach nicht verfolgt
wie viel leiden wie viel Zerstörung wie
viel mörderung wie viel Vergewaltigung
die Ukraine erlitten haben wie viele
Menschen sind ermöglicht letztendlich
wurden und das glaube ich Dieter Bohlen
hat total verpasst und deswegen redet er
eigentlich Sachen die schon vorher
gemacht wurden und Russland vorher auch
gewarnt wohnt gewarnt worden nicht die
Ukraine anzugreifen nicht diese
internationalen Recht zu brechen seit
Zweiten Weltkrieg in Europa so ein
riesenkrieg gab es noch seit 2 Weltkrieg
nicht ohne glaube dass Dieter Bohlen hat
es voll verpasst
wenn Dieter Bohlen jetzt sagen würde
ich komme nach Kiew ich schaue mir das
mal an wärst du bereit ihn hier
rumzuführen du kennst ihn ja aus der
Vergangenheit glaubst du man kann ihn
davon überzeugen was was hier wirklich
passiert
ich glaube wenn man das mit alten
eigenen Augen sieht natürlich sieht man
in butsche nicht mehr das was man Anfang
März gesehen hat aber trotzdem
an diesem Montag diese Woche Montag habe
ich schon wieder
Teile der Leichen gesehen die verstreut
waren nach einer Explosion in Stadtmitte
schon wieder das mörderung des
Zivilisten passierte in Hauptstadt und
weit in den ganzen Land die Ukraine und
deswegen die glaube schon dass ein
Besuch in tief wird schon definitiv viel
Verstand für Dieter wollen geben also
wir halten fest Wladimir Klitschko wäre
bereit Dieter Bohlen hier die Realität
zu zeigen wenn man nach diesem Video
diesen Applaus gehört hat dann zeigt das
ja doch dass Dieter Bohlen offenbar
keine Einzelstimme ist sondern das ist
mehrere wie viele es sind durchaus ein
Prozentzahl an Menschen gibt die sagen
diese Sanktionen bringen nichts was ist
dein Gefühl wie sehr ist diese Haltung
in Deutschland verbreitet
jeder hat letztendlich eigene Meinung
über die verschiedenen Situationen auf
der ganzen Welt fakt ist dessen
transnale riecht ist seit Ende Februar
gebrochen worden
zigtausende Zivilisten sind ermordet
worden
Infrastruktur ist zerstört worden und es
geht täglich immer weiter mit beschossen
von
Drohnen iranische Drohnen von russische
altari und vor allem auch Raketen
es ist nicht mehr sicher in der Ukraine
zu sein egal wo man ist und es ist
wichtig sich damit zu beschäftigen und
nicht sagen Sport Kunst und weiteres hat
nichts mit der Politik zu tun hier
passiert ein Krieg
und dann kriegst Verbrechen eingehen
erzählt dekrainischen Volkes und das
darf nicht weiter so gehen weil nur in
der Ukraine laut der russische
Propaganda werden ihn nicht stehen
bleiben und ist immer weiter rollen wird
wir haben schon eine vergangene in der
Vergangenheit auch erlebt ist
Ostblock auch in Deutschland
Ostdeutschland und Westdeutschland war
schon mal geteilt und die Konsequenzen
wie sich das Volk das deutsche Volk im
Osten gestürmt hat und vor allem auch
diese Nähe zu bringen
wollte auch und letztendlich dass diese
Mauerfall passierte es zeigt dass die
Mehrheit Menschen wer ein gesunden
Verstand haben sind zufrieden und nicht
für den Krieg dennoch gibt es nicht nur
in Deutschland die Debatte darum dass
die gastkosten jetzt hoch sind Menschen
Mittelständler sagen sie müssen ihre
Geschäfte zu machen was sagst du
denjenigen auch in Deutschland die sagen
ich nehme lieber Gas aus Russland als
Pleite zu gehen
es ist eine kurzfristige
Verband auf eine tiefe Wunde zu stellen
kurzfristige das gut gehen
wahrscheinlich
oder sogar sicherlich gut gehen
langfristig sie werden von der Wunde
sterben wie auch immer dann Konsequenzen
Aussehen nach eine tiefe Wunde wie
gesagt wir sind leichten Pflaster drauf
zu tun wird eigentlich wie gesagt nicht
wirklich für eine Heilung
helfen deswegen die ganze Welt ist
eigentlich und auch schon heute
dazugestimmt hat dass diese sogenannte
Referendum im Osten und Süden der
Ukraine
wird nicht akzeptiert von den ganzen
Welt mit einer Ausnahme oder paar
Ausnahmen handfolie Ausnahmen und nicht
mehr von Nordkorea
Weißrussland was auch eine Union
sozusagen ist mit Russland auch in
diesem Krieg um Unterstützung und von
weißrussischen Grenzen oder von
Weißrussland fliegen immer weitere
Raketen und auf den ukrainischen Boden
und letztendlich die ganze Welt zeigt
sich gegen diesen brutalen Krieg gegen
diese Völkermord ganz schnell zum
Abschluss zirkulierten Video von 99
wetten dass Vitali Klitschko und du
zusammen dort mit Dieter Bohlen wo
Stefan Raab singt könnt ihr ihn mal
versohlen hast du es geschafft
ich brauche das nicht anschauen ich
erinnere das sogar sehr
Humor wieder gehört dazu und ich glaube
das weitere Kommentar was das betrifft
außer Humor kann ich nicht machen aber
ganz ganz sicher ich glaube schon dass
wenn Dieter Bohlen die Ukraine anreist
und das mit eigenen Augen sieht wie das
Land funktioniert wenn das Krieges ich
glaube das wird ihm helfen auch die Welt
bestehen herzlichen Dank Wladimir
Klitschko und damit zurück nach Berlin
[Musik]